Hey, David, is the idea of impeaching Trump
over?
I'm not hearing very much about it, but at
the same time, supposedly Jerry Nadler is
running an impeachment inquiry.
What the Hell is going on?
So listen, here's the answer.
I don't care either way.
And what I mean by that is we should know
if there's going to be an impeachment inquiry
or not.
But I've said before, at this point, the possibility
of the impeachment inquiry is doing nothing
for the left.
It's a distraction.
Okay?
If anything, it's hurting the left internal
debates about should we do an impeachment
inquiry or should we not do an impeachment
inquiry?
Pelosi says no, and Nadler says yes, or whoever
says yes, no, whatever.
And they get into these arguments.
That's how you lose.
Okay?
Option one, start the impeachment inquiry.
Right away.
I'm fine with that.
I think that that would be damaging to Donald
Trump.
It would take away some of the power of Donald
Trump's narrative setting a ability within
the media.
That would be fine.
Decide we're going to table the impeachment
inquiry until, for example, November 1st,
2019 or February 1st, 2020 or whenever Democrats
say this is when the impeachment inquiry will
be most damaging to Donald Trump.
Great.
I'm fine with that as well.
Yes, it's playing politics.
Oh No, it's okay.
If that's the idea that we could do more damage
to Trump by starting the impeachment inquiry
at some later point, let's do it.
Or no impeachment inquiry, let's just win
2020 and put our efforts on that.
I'm fine with that as well, so I don't know
if the idea of impeaching Trump is over or
more accurately doing the impeachment inquiry,
which would be the first step.
The the, the sort of pre impeachment inquiry.
I don't really care as long as everybody is
on the same page and we understand what the
impeachment inquiry would lead to and what
it would not lead to.
The impeachment inquiry would lead to making
public a lot of the content of the Mueller
report, which most people haven't read.
That's good.
It will damage Trump.
It will lead to media stories about the impeachment
inquiry.
That's good.
That's time that is not being manipulated
by Donald Trump and other good things.
The impeachment inquiry will not lead to the
removal of Donald Trump via an impeachment
conviction in the Senate.
It just won't.
Okay, so as long as we understand what it
will and won't do, I'm fine with doing it
now, doing it in six months or doing it, not
at all, but we've got to stop going back and
forth about it.
And in that sense, I'm not displeased.
That discussions of impeachment has sort of
evaporated.
Meanwhile, though, based on Trump's erratic
behavior over the last 10 days or so since
we started and since ended our show vacation,
more and more discussions of removal under
the 25th Amendment for being unfit to serve
have surfaced and are perpetuating themselves
and social media also don't know that that's
going to go anywhere, but I'm totally fine
with uh, not pursuing impeachment against
Donald Trump and I'm completely fine with
doing it as well.